[Music]
so
[Music]
me
[Music]
this
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
maybe
[Music]
this
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
i definitely
[Music]
uh
[Music]
i'll cut everything off
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
me
[Music]
sure
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
me
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
what
actually that's better oh no
get in the actual frame actually get a
little bit more all right there we go
what's going on guys you should be able
to hear me i'm assuming you can hear me
let me do a mic check real quick
talk
testing testing
five four three two one
[Music]
all right trying to
hello hello all right
we'll be able to hear that better
all right so this is what we'll do
we got the
let me bring this up a little bit
we got the
the game here
i think that's fine
we're gonna go ahead and start exactly
where we're yesterday
now i think haley was first so you're
most likely going to
yeah to
to take it
yeah so haley was first
you wanna load this this one here
i gotta i gotta keep my thingy off my
ear cause i can't really hear you
no no that's fine all right
well i'm gonna put it like that because
it hurts when i put it back
all right that's fine
we gotta communicate with each other
anyway so it's your turn
we caitlyn
the cool asian chick
asian chick that's right you can't get
it killed
oh this is going to be the part of the
game where
i can't hear
the game oh i know why don't worry about
it
do you need my question i only get my
phone back it's just a big dumb brick
here we go guys
let me share this out while you're doing
that okay
okay
easily
all right so share this
copy
hey caitlin guess what
mr h is a voyeuristic creep he has
hidden cameras everywhere and a secret
room
no that's not
uh oh no backup what his eyes are
everywhere he's always watching us [ __ ]
it off man he's just got
trail cameras set up you know for
surveillance that kind of thing
oh you don't think that's weird well
he's got a perimeter to check kids to
protect he'll probably just to keep
track of wildlife you guys have no
imagination so uh
what's going on here everything ready
still no service
ah yeah
zoo
pretty boring
i wonder maybe a satellite fell out of
the sky or something yeah and landed in
the forest waking from her slumber the
hacking okay
you know i just realized we may never
see each other again after tonight
you can't have just realized that
what mood what mood the vibe you know
speaking of setting the mood
i have work to do okay because playlists
don't make themselves
i mean i guess they do but
all right right guy time to get wood
yikes wording
oh i know what i said
abby nick just in time
we got wood
we've already done that joke
it's mostly just kindling um
there's already a big pile of vlogs here
this is what it's not like to wear as a
hog
my bad dude michael was very very brave
and took one for the team
we uh we we've been gosh it can't be
it's been a chaotic week man it's been a
chaotic week what
thought you hated that phrase
big jokes take big sacrifices
you're so brave
oh i just want to shrink you down to
little pocket people and put you in my
pocket and peep it to where i need a
little pick me up she is so cr extra
yeah
definitely
you could tell she's that person no one
likes
financial delivery
i probably am
whoa whoa whoa where the hell did that
gun come from dude relax okay it's not
even real uh well i mean it's a real gun
but it's just for shooting bears i found
it in the storage room
okay fine fine we'll put it down thank
you guns are no joke [ __ ]
and and
we bring you a hand-picked selection of
only the finest that hackett's quarry
has to offer no freaking way yes
freaking way
peanut butter butter puffs
pop pop
pop them in my mouth come on am i what
please hand me the shotgun
what you gonna shoot me over them no
dumbass okay we are going to
shoot for them
nah dude absolutely not no
oh not leaving you with a gun
yeah i feel like that's something she
would say wait i'm leaving you dill
weeds alone with a gun
the shooting range is like right over
there okay it'll be fun okay look
you and me
old-fashioned shootout first prize
peanut butter butter pops
all to yourself
dude i guess you don't really want them
then huh
fine you're on yeah boy
jacob hand me that gun now i mean
nobody's handling any firearms if you're
gonna act like a dick about it okay then
you can be the ref we need an objective
third party okay we're trying to get a
party started here jk well the main part
is not going to die just cause you're
offering a little side quest
come on
all right
guess we're gonna have ourselves an
old-fashioned shootout
there's a clearing we can use as a
shooting range back there but if i see
either be [ __ ] around i am turning
this car around
i love how they need her
she's like her justice my case
it's like they blindly listen to her too
they're scared of her
that's what it is they're scared of her
it's scared that she's going
all right it's nick
all right all right i don't think nick
was one of the ones shooting wasn't he
yeah i'm pretty sure nick was one of the
ones shooting
so
just so you know i was an expert
marksman
third class
three years in a row ranked highest in
camp each year i'm just letting you know
that your goose is cooked nick i wonder
if i'm going to actually shoot the gun
one little peanut butter probably like a
mini game or something no way you've
never even seen me shoot yeah that's
because you've never shot before you
know that you know of
okay i think i would know if you're next
boys i'm gonna have to stop you right
there as much as i'm enjoying your
charming matismo the moment we step foot
on the shooting range we're pulling by
my rules okay and what i say goes got it
okay good now i'm gonna go set up some
targets and get more shells do not move
a muscle or touch this gun until i'm
back why don't you just bring the gun
because you don't want it is it just me
is it kind of hot when she cuts out
i'm always hot pencilled okay thank you
bye bye
if you drop a gun
so um
was your little one-on-one without me
it was hopeful
i feel like
it was actually like
it was a disaster
they've been her
i think he should be helpful though no i
think it was a disaster i think he
should be hopeful because like
he likes her
and she likes him there were some very
clear mixed signals in that conversation
there was but like
it's awkward they're awkward around each
other that's why
um
how is your little one-on-one with
it's incredible
she's totally still into me
really yeah
just got to figure out this whole
long distance thing he's totally lying
well she she did say to what's her name
to abigail that she did
she didn't like him it was just like the
the long distance thing she wanted to
deal with so
speaking of let me show you how a real
man shoots his gun are you guys
seriously still thumping your chest at
each other no i think he's got bright
damage
okay please just give me the gun uh-uh
you'll have it when i say you'll have it
all right hold up
you're shooting the one on the left nick
first then jacob's turn
keep your fingers off the trigger until
you're ready to shoot you got it
what are they gonna do this
two things
remember the spread remember the recoil
this is a shotgun we're not sharp
shooting here the flashlight shows you
where
she can be in it if she wants
all right so
oh
all right nick one point
i feel like he's gonna destroy her
though i don't want to little
i nudged her and she got off the table
herself
all right all right here we go here we
go
nice shot
oh here we go
oh i'm doing it
showing off
point to you nick
point that was like five good job nick
all right
let's see what you got
all right you might want to uh
avert your eyes nick i don't want to
give you any more performance anxiety
oh god shut up and shoot jacob
i thought you're an ultra elite pro yeah
with like a rifle okay not with this
blaster that is how you get someone shot
no it's okay you probably would have
missed me anyway
no
sorry jacob better luck next time
better look next time hey i didn't want
to say it but you're both very mean
i bet you father missed a couple
blam we thought this was over
whoa
hot pop peanut butter butter pops
[Laughter]
she wasn't in this
she missed a watermelon
brian i've been feeling stuff's about to
go south
this seems like i thought he told them
to stay inside
don't make noise
i mean they're doing everything that
they're not supposed to be doing
and they're even out at night like i
have a feeling it's about to get real
south real fast
[Music]
i think there's a lot of people gonna
die
sooner or later huh
is it cold
we'll go get you some
okay
take the blanket off the party game
i think it's in there we might never see
each other after tonight let's make some
memories just go grab it real quick if
you're cold
the ultimate grab the top blanket off
the bed lies truth or dare but dylan's
style
okay house rules are
someone asks you truth or dare
then you choose and then you do
and there's no ifs ands or butts
so like normal truth or dare
yes be careful so we can like make
people kiss
if they choose dare yeah as long as oh
god
of course
what
is i mean keep it in your pants until
it's your turn but well who does get to
go first
well it's house deals so
abigail here we go
truth or dare
um
really dodged a bullet huh
all right here goes you're gonna let me
ask them
have you ever slept with anyone
oh uh
i
she regretting saying truth is she
interrupts
hey
take it easy man that's too far
come on
i'm not finished um
dylan's like interruption
at this camp
no
no
sorry all right abby it's your turn
nick
all right okay um
oh abby oh my god just pick someone
okay okay um
i don't know
nick
oh ding ding ding too late my turn
ryan
truth or dare
dare
give me what you got
okay ryan
your dare comes with a choice oh god did
you do that
i can do whatever i want
and i dare you to kiss either caitlyn
or dylan wow
i mean i guess both is off the table
sorry
i don't make the
literally just made the rules
come on babe
come on you know kids dylan dylan
sorry
she did that on purpose
oh
i don't know what you're trying to say
all righty who shall i pick well uh me
and jacob haven't gotten their turn yet
good point
jacob
all right jacob let's see what you're
made of oh they're lighting this up here
man come on
okay
i dare you
to take the lying leap over that fire
pit
naked
[ __ ] yes oh i will jump over this thing
i don't care he he seems like he's been
waiting for his whole life idea
no
jacob
wait don't do it
stop
dude i say vito you're gonna [ __ ]
yourself up
what
look come on man i got this brian come
on
vito you know what
[ __ ] this game
someone else can go okay fine anyway it
was hardcore when i fly over that's it
emma
there
emma so you have to kiss
you're going to say someone besides
jacob
jacob
or
nick
she's going to pick me
well then
um
uh sorry nick this is not there
obviously i don't know how good idea
i choose nick
seriously see she gotta die first she's
an ass
like her friend
is digging that [ __ ] that dude and she
knows it
guys uh
women are so
messed up
that is definitely not just a kid
she sat on his lap
he's dead emma is dead
thank you nick
oh now he's mad
he's good
you're like kissing my girlfriend
[ __ ]
oh god
he was just a guy i'm nobody's
girlfriend the [ __ ] it was just a game
yeah the [ __ ] it was man oh god
jacob
grow up
yeah see now they're separating so now
people are about to start dying probably
go after him
but i'm not you should probably go find
abby
does she really not think there was
anybody want to play
any consequences to that decision
she did it on purpose babe clearly
just to get abby jealous and also
um what's his face oh god
it's going
but more has been found
yes
the hanged man
to be the hanged man is to surrender
and by doing so
gain a new perspective so look carefully
and consider that sometimes one needs to
be strung up in order to let go
well she's
right now she's telling you a way to
save someone there's more to show you
if you'll let me
see more or move on um move on
we don't want much help from her is that
what you're saying
but the last thing i want to do is take
your choices from you
like mine were taken from you
i wonder who she is maybe she's someone
from like a previous game or something
secrets remain buried
you're not just calming on this woman's
shoulders
they look just luxurious aren't they
they're luxurious luxurious luxury
luxurious
i'm just like what's the little finger
thing
chef's kiss
chef
chef's kiss
abigail
yes
i have a feeling this is gonna be the
first chapter someone can die on
um
oh god freaks in the chat
you are being a little extra with the
shoulders like you are being a little
extra
what me yeah you are you seem like you
like those shoulders a lot all i said
was you like those shoulders a lot
you're the one who's dragging it on
my kitty alone you're being a meanie but
to me
watch you get abigail killed this
chapter
i think she's gonna get abigail killed
this
chapter shut up
i'm just i'm just being honest sit there
and pet my cat i am
this is my cat excuse me sir it's not
like a skill for that cat no you won't
you ain't do [ __ ]
you wanna
oh the car car car the tower
god
yeah yeah boy your boy boy
i don't even know where he went so i'm
just
like well he left after you left you
left first so she's not going after
anyone she's just walking
oh yeah that's right but now she's
scared
because she's an idiot she just got
herself killed
abby
shout out again
i'm over here i'm over here nick nick
hey
nick
hey i'm over here
hi
hi
what is all what is looking at them it's
definitely not human
it's got night vision it look like
yes
oh invasive invasive too much smoke got
a little intense
should have been invasive i think that
game just got a little too intense for
me
yeah i know what you mean
[Music]
i think i think um
so you and him you're gonna be direct or
you're gonna be
cautious
movie directors oh direct guess emma's
had a thing for you all along huh
what
no no no way she was just trying to make
jacob jealous
i was just
playing along
you seem to enjoy playing along
he was getting a little into that game
jacob jealous
that's
about it
no you just being a little into into
that kiss
he just got through kissing another
woman and now you in the in the woods
making out with them
look all i'm saying see that that's that
bad
blood women be having
like man
how are you gonna kiss someone that was
literally just kissing it out
yes
it's not rambling it's facts ramble
around it's facts
that chick
look all i'm saying is
he was just
helping him out
it looked like he was enjoying that
helping out
don't hate the players
yeah see there's a little bit enjoying
going on there
is that a tiger with having two chicks
is that a tiger
want to be a black panther
is that a bear it's me it's too fast
did you see what it looked like oh
that's that thing in the basement
[Music]
oh what are you doing what are you gonna
do
obviously oh my god
who's shooting
someone
i bet you those rednecks are there to
oh
we gonna do good already you can hide
hey
you can't get going
oh this is intense
so either way she leaves nick
climb the tree climb the tree
you think that's going to help you
you just got her killed
[Music]
oh my god
you
you feel such a
s
you feel like such a failure right now
okay you don't have to rub it in my face
thanks
thanks
it's a fun game
nick's dead
i think
i don't i don't know
i think
who thinks nick's dead
[Music]
you did kind of fail abigail right there
okay
you messed up two qtes in a row
no
i can't believe you just got them killed
[Music]
it's not
going to
stop
until you
know it's not going to stop
i told you that was gonna be the first
chapter someone getting killed didn't i
yeah but she's not dead
i got to keep people it was live as long
you got my you got one of my people
killed
this stuff
maybe he would have been he would have
died no i feel like you could have saved
him i did i chose to save him instead of
just i feel like if you would have ran
maybe they would have ran with you
yeah yeah i guess
jacob
i thought we agreed that
this
us
it's just supposed to be some summer fun
so we're not over the text
oh
yeah no no no nick's not dead he's not i
know i just somebody's finished this
game
no he beat the game dylan from the
quarry
i mean you just
you know i love the guy but i don't
think he's actually ever seen a girl
naked before well i hate to break it to
you but he just had his tongue down my
throat and he definitely knew what to do
with it
oh that's this oh you you really love
[ __ ] with me huh lighten up
therapists please
you know what nothing
no nothing never mind
fine
you can stand here sulking
driving yourself crazy imagining nick's
tongue in my mouth
[Music]
you can go grab us some towels
[Music]
what do you need towels for
well
we agreed
some are fun right
apparently
summer is not
quite
he going straight for those towels
someone's about to die too
she gonna jump in
that water do me looking creepy though
i knew it
i told you didn't i who that is
is he tied to something it looks like
he's tied to something
i think he was tied to something it was
like
the definition of
preppy
v
woman i'm sorry i can't oh look look
you found a tear card
i found the store
all right so let's look around
the moon dna yes
was she on this
no oh no there she is
to see if there's any towels
why would they be towels are just
randomly laying on the toe
where else would they be babe i don't
know there's probably like an out shack
or something that they're there
maybe up here
an out chat
sorry this is
all
right there's no towels
none there's exactly zero
what are these numbers
but
it's a non-refundable thing
i don't know
nobody's died yet if that's what you're
meaning to anybody get popped
no i think uh i think abigail's dead
you think abigail's dead yeah and i
think you killed him i think i don't
think abigail's dead yeah i think you
killed her
no she ran
she's gonna come back to camp
she got her neck bit
felt like there was something over here
where is
is there nothing else but
all right i'm gonna stop
yeah i'm gonna stop reading the chat
he's ruining it he's ruining it
i'm gonna start reading the chat
oh abigail was affected while nick might
die okay
if i'm not dead just half dead
what's up facts what's up
all right so let's go see what's going
on
yeah but what is she infected with like
the monster's blood rabies rabies
she turns into the monster okay well i
guess we could just like
drip dry or
you could shake it out doggy style wow
you really know how to talk to yourself
look you can't just pretend that it
didn't happen
oh but i can because
you see oh help help i'm i'm drowning
and i i need a big stretch you're gonna
get snatched not at all insecure man to
come save me
my man cooks after me which man
cannonball
okay
what's this a female involved
fragile thing for hurricane jake is here
cannonball oh
god
we just randomly came off
feel like i'm getting someone's
attention by splashing
she's gonna go down and see the dead
body
something's about to happen
or she's gonna get snatched
something's happening
okay hey
look
something's happening
okay
take a picture of me
yeah for your like um
little subscribers or whatever top 10
guys who will keep you satisfied
so i get nine more
she is so ridiculous
is she finally gonna get snatched
i bet you that was what's your name
sorry
but then he's gonna leave
what's his name linda oh [ __ ]
as best we all stay together let's go
get uh let's go get
actually i should have left her there
jagen
dick
oh god
there's no way
that water is that clear
he's gonna get stuck somewhere
go man get up
[ __ ] that's intense
that was intense
now i'm ryan
i assume ryan's a dylan
huh i said why would they not be
actually there was case there's some
mighty fine social disruption there
kaitlyn i have to say ah or is it just
the nudge that abby needed
you're an evil genius
[Laughter]
who do you think is gonna make the first
move
nick robbie oh good cue
my bet's on either i don't know nick's
got the beast in them huh if by beast
you mean some sort of mild-mannered baby
deer
hey don't let that cute preppy aesthetic
fool you it's like a steel board
[Applause]
yeah just the three of us
all right dylan
true third
oh
that's the shotgun oh my gosh
we gotta help her
wait where did it come from
this way come on
she got the gun that's the right chick
with the gun too
help him
where's
nick i
oh i feel like we're about to get some
people killed
go after nick go
maybe
she's got the gun
i gotta help abby go he might be hurt
too
cool
okay yeah give me the gun then give me
the shotgun's got a hell of a spread be
careful oh god oh god
i feel like they're gonna keep caitlyn
alive the majority of the
because you're not really plays caitlyn
that whole lot
we played her with like one section of
one chapter
and it was really just for no she helped
with the shotgun thing
okay here we go
i got to keep nick alive
is getting better
better boys
take the shortcut
and then take the shortcut oh god
oh
made it one
got to do it again
made it again
oh
grab it grab it get up there
i should have took that shortcut that
was a lot of risky stuff business right
there
it could have went very bad for us yes
another shortcut
i'm in the risky business department
i only believe in risky business now we
need to make something
risky
oh i'm taking the shortcuts all the way
there
oh
oh god there's a lot of these
hey
get the [ __ ] off of him
shoot the gun stop stop
yo he just took that shot [ __ ] dude
it just walked like it was nothing not
not
i saved him babe i say you do they were
about to snatch out dude can have that
happen he would have went down either
way
what happens if these people end up
being like
what
once these people end up being like our
saviors
i don't know
what if they don't what if they're
trying to save them i mean i mean you
could be right
he's in his underwear why is he running
through the woods in his underwear he
should have put his clothes on i don't
know he did jump in that lake
oh yeah he wanted to drifter
oh he's dripping drying
oh jesus
girl waiting for you back there jacob
what are you doing
you know i saw that stuff from the gym
the other day is it still in the
refrigerator you forgot
[Music]
remember
all right here we go here we go
my heart beat man
i'm not calling out i'm not calling out
more clothes
there's no way i'm gonna call out
[Music]
upside down
they said to be patient remember
[Music]
i would be bleeding babe i won't be oh
please please man just just let me down
okay
just
don't hurt me please
oh jesus christ what the [ __ ] are you
doing he's cutting you down
i think they're hunters trying to kill
that thing i don't think they're bad
people
but we did shoot one
[ __ ]
look how bulky that dude is i can't
believe he got shot he's still [ __ ]
quiet
helps if you close your eyes
what are you doing
stop
help
oh
it tastes bad
it's for your own good
i bet you that's like a repellent for
that thing what are you off to now girly
if he was wanting to kill us he would
have killed him
[ __ ]
he's trying he they're trying to capture
that thing that's why there's a boar
there
counterweight they're trying to capture
seems like just a blink and you're back
to see me again
do you wanna um so
then
what have we got
it's the star
stars
stars in the night
sky
beacons of light
dreams of hope purpose
or a reminder of our insignificance
fear of despair
trust in the light of the star with it
comes clarity
and sometimes pointed at um 10.
the toe
jump free of your troubles go in there
and see if that's um
while we're doing this that's the thing
often when leaping out of danger we're
still faced with certain peril
watch your step
it could be your last
remember
there's always more than meets the eye
would you like me to show you
yes
good
but i can only delve deeper into one
possible future
so which is one of the people in the
chat want to see uh
the tarot card for the tower
back to it then
back to hackett's quarry
back to atkins quarry you go
it's creepy
interesting
we just completed chapter three babe
i said i'm knit go ahead and just start
making that even know what it was it was
so fast and and there was okay then
light up you saw
oh abby
here
what oh try drawing
trying what
can you draw would attack you
oh he's hurt
nick
hey buddy
nick's been through it man was happy
man
we need to know what happened
all right
there was
there was a guy there but
there's some kind of
some kind of adam
what [ __ ] kind of animal does this
man he's been through it
abby
she's okay dude she's right over there
because
teeth run on top of me
i think she was a bear
full size bear would have crushed them
there's no way i thought we don't get
bears right here
oh this is raw [ __ ] look at that oh [ __ ]
that black stuff
that's that's infection that's and it's
it's spreading this is bad this is
really bad dude
[Music]
sorry i think i might have infected nick
by accident i don't know
you're okay it's okay
[ __ ] that
we should amputate
we should cut it off before the
infection spreads
what
they want to amputate his leg
why would we do that
i don't know man look at that black
stuff
what what do you think it is
do i look like a doctor
i don't know man i don't think we should
be cutting people's legs off
but will they
if you don't cut the leg off
and he's been bitten
he'll uh
he'll turn
i don't know
we're not calling out we letting them
come out
i was like why can't i hear nothing
see someone else still does it like
regardless what you say
what if it's jacob or emma what if it's
not
okay now i can't hear none of them
like i can hear the music but i can't
hear them talking
don't plug it back in
it was probably nothing
yeah
but is it gone
all right tell me when it's plugged down
it's plugged in
yeah you better run okay
very brave
all right
so uh
law just sounding pretty good right
about now yeah
is it working
don't shoot don't shoot
i'm here to save you
holy [ __ ]
that's my boyfriend it's [ __ ] up
is he okay
nick and abby were attacked i don't know
what you're doing but like every time
you pull it out a little bit does
anybody have any dry clothes i don't
know why they're still in the minivan
that worked
working it's like halfway in
is it working
i mean yeah when it's halfway in
jacob
where's emma oh
[ __ ] oh jesus christ um
i i left
emma on the island and i told her i'd be
right back
ouch
wait the island
yeah why
well no i just
i just thought i saw someone over there
before
someone
no i you know i i don't know it's
probably nothing i'd love to ride there
alone
well i think we're gonna head to the
lodge
also why are you covered in
what i hope is strawberry jelly
oh yeah no um
i'm pretty sure it's blood
it's like a like a bottle
thing i don't know dude it's like a
really long story
ew
yeah
super [ __ ] up oh my god can you guys
hear an echo oh jesus christ i can't
believe i'm gonna tell you this
i saw a [ __ ] body in the lake
like a dead one
oh no no no no um yeah i can't hear one
of the one of the swimmers from the
varsity swim team he got lost on the way
to practice and it was yes a dead one
dumb ass of course you did jacob no for
real i did i i figured it must have been
one of the counselors that didn't show
up but i couldn't tell because it was
like okay oh blow me
uh excuse me hey i need this okay it's
not safe out there dude we gotta pretend
yeah and i need to save emma all right
she's out there alone you don't even
know if she's in trouble it might be the
headset
are you trying to piss me off my wife
i'm trying to save my girlfriend's life
[ __ ] yeah i don't think she's your
girlfriend dude
well let's let's try it
[ __ ]
oh
[ __ ] stop we're in a real mess here
guys you're acting like pricks both of
you
jacob we're keeping this nick and abby
are injured we need protection there's
someone around here
ryan sorry
this is [ __ ]
make sure she's safe if she's on the
island she's definitely fine
all right now just try just to see i
don't know what another run-in with
captain deliverance no thanks okay
there's probably another boat by the zip
line either way i can make it to the
island from there are you sure yeah
we need to get back to the lodge try to
get help
how nick can't walk properly
yeah i have an idea
the wheelbarrow
probably gonna play emma next i don't
know why i have a feeling
yeah
you're right okay let's see what tonight
brings
okay here's a riddle for you what's got
two thumbs and it's suddenly riding solo
on a freaky island in the dark
this fool
well
one thumb one
available thumb
okay
and it was here
on a strange uninhabited island that
this brave young soul found herself
i don't like how i feel like
even though that we picked to do stuff
they still do something the same thing
yeah a strange tiny little island all
alone with nothing to do but show you
guys around so there's a tree house over
there i'm gonna go and see if i can't
dish out some of that sweet sweet
panoramic goodness
because here's the thing
not that i want to go back because i
don't but even if i did
i can't because then i'd look like the
super needy one when he was the one who
who stormed off in the first place
god you know what sorry i'm venting oh
explore venting you know what [ __ ] it
let's do it to the tree house fellow
explorers
so this island is like an unexcavated
part of the quarry that rewilded itself
after it flooded into the lake
pretty cool huh
you know when i was little
i used to think that islands just kind
of would float in the middle of the
water kind of like an air bed
but
i'm older and wiser now and
realize that not everything's always as
it seems kind of like how you thought
you were just having a hot summer fling
and then it turns into babysitting a big
hairy manchester oh my god he's all sad
because you don't want to go steady with
him and write him love letters every
freaking day and while we're talking
about it
you don't mind that we're talking about
it right
why
why is it up to me to justify my
feelings when he's the one who got all
bluff about it you know
oh look
i might afford the narrative by means of
fork in the road how fitting
here's the big question
do i
take the high road literally
and forget about it
or
do i continue on the path i'm on and
keep ranting about my stupid time life
i guess since this isn't live
the choice is up to me
gosh did not shut up
and this
is the meeting shelter
it's a shelter
where you
meet at
okay i'm trying really hard to make this
interesting but
sometimes a thing just
is what it is
i think i've made my point
she really doesn't
she literally never stops talking she
literally never stops talking it's all
about her babe
miss chris over here
that's probably where you came from yeah
it is
maybe there's a card down here
[Music]
yeah the magician
ah nice
let's go kind of figure there's
something down there
i mean it let me go down there so i
figured something was down there
i wish you can walk faster though
yeah they do that for like a cinematic
pace
but
i don't like that [ __ ]
no god
okay moving up in the world let's do
this
now you might notice the darling rustic
vibes this walkway is radiating and
that's no accident i don't know what
y'all are doing with your walkways but
if you're not spending a full hour
pulling a splinter out of a snotty kid's
finger don't you dare call it authentic
don't worry the kid was fine i'm a good
counselor and what doesn't kill you will
make you stronger
no just give you trouble
she would be a good vlogger
[Music]
she is making what doesn't kill you she
is making climbing up from stairs a
little entertaining so
i think she'd be a good vlogger
very
pretty
i mean she's still gonna die a very
annoying blogger how about that
yeah but the annoying bloggers are the
one that makes makes a lot of money
they're the ones that get bigger i like
that dude um that we watch oh yeah
oh this is this
and where did is just see that person on
the other side of the lake
i know but like now you can't see it
this is where we're heading
not too shabby well literally is too
shabby but these views oh man you're
gonna blow your tops
there's also a zip line which
i guess you can watch me crap my pants
on that thing what the hell
i'm here aren't i i'm gonna carpe this
dm so damn hard it won't know what hit
it
first we gotta get there and there's
still so much to talk about
i know what jacob's problems are i hope
abby's okay
i hope abby's okay
she ran off earlier if you didn't see it
i kind of sort of made out with nick but
it was a dare i'm not like a [ __ ] or
anything
oh into context abby likes nick
well actually they like each other
in truth
i just wanted to fan the flames a little
watching them stumble around each other
like drunk jellyfish was exhausting
poor kid was like a deer in headlights
it's cool though they're smart they'll
get it i bet they're out there in the
woods right now just absolutely going
for it
yeah she's just recording herself
she's not live
i have a feeling sheep
she's about to die
are we gonna do are we actually gonna
yeah a little bit what
huh are we gonna try to keep her
her alive or
or what um let her jump up
i thought she was really going to jump
up yeah
ah dang it
i don't think she knows there's monsters
yet she's like the only person that
hasn't
been affected by everything yet
oh look
car keys
police car keys
i think this might be one of those i'm
sorry officer i've no idea what you're
talking about situations so i'm just
gonna go ahead and leave those right
there
no pick them up
oh man
i don't feel like there's a lot of
choice in this game
and here we are
as promised one extremely rickety and
even more underwhelming tree house
in another world perhaps young jacob and
i would settle down here and play house
together
honey i'm home
what's that now
i forgot the children's bedtime
well now that's a fine how do you do
what is she
yo
take it all in folks that's the summer
camp experience right there and
oh look it seems somebody forgot to
clear the place out
i guess one of the kids left their stuff
or maybe one of the guys back there
but
i don't recognize this
did you hear that
looks like we have a choice on our hands
do we snoop through someone else's
belongings or do we open the spooky trap
door and die a horrible painful death
open the trapdoor
we're with time yeah
open the trap door you know we got to
open the trap door yeah we got a letter
guy come on
watch we try to get this woman killed
and she doesn't
final curtain is calling and there's no
time for an encore
yo
save her
we good we good
i can't believe i didn't think she was
gonna die i think that we was able to
make her die honestly
there you go
yo that was crazy i can't believe she
died she did yep she did she out of
there easy
i got it he's okay
are you in pain
no no sorry i'm just
i'm really hungry
we'll get you some food inside okay
[Laughter]
oh man we wasn't trying to deal with her
i don't know if he'll be able to find
you a horse but
maybe some granola
we're not going to play the game how
it's supposed to
do we're here to save people we will
well we're supposed to it's just we
didn't like her
like at all
the game's better this will open the
nurse's station should be plenty of
stuff in there well hopefully we can
just get him cleaned up for now
i'll get you something you know what's
really sad though
we opened a monster up though
so now they're gonna they might have
been on the side you might have
been free regardless um isn't there one
in mr h's office
nope
we'll come meet you
copy that
i really hope they're gonna be okay do
you think that whatever's left in the
nurse's office is gonna cut it
kayla knows what she's doing
does she i mean she wasn't even supposed
to be working at the nurse's office this
summer she only filled in because some
other girl didn't show up she still did
it though
come on let's go call for backup
not liking this dude now why oh no
pretty weird to see this place so dead
oh
no emma was the only one that had to go
[Laughter]
if i had to go i couldn't handle much
more emma in this game all right way too
much
where are you going
i
i i thought i just heard my name
i didn't hear anything
maybe i do
maybe i do
isn't that something you'll never know i
don't think nick's injuries are as bad
as we thought
i can get them all killed
all of them troy addicts
well that's good news
yeah
so what now
this is this is getting pretty chaotic
for help
who should i call
uh
mr h
the only number i got is to this phone
okay then 90-1-1
you mean 9-1-1 who says 91-1
i don't know
why are they arguing just hit 9-1-1
should i ask for like police everything
huh
cops
with guns we need a lot of backup out
here
so they'll say 9-1-1 what's your
emergency and then i say i'm not liking
nick now maybe nick got to go nice my
friends may have been attacked by a bear
or maybe not a bear but definitely an
animal with teeth
and we're not sure how many there are do
you think we need to go to this much
detail on why we might be
mounting an attack on us right now and
we really need backup what
he's overthinking this whole situation
yeah yeah that's
good what's wrong
good
well that's weird
phones go dead sometimes out here right
when you're about to call the cops
though it's a coincidence
you try the hang up thingy what
here
what are you doing i don't know it's
what they do in movies when the phone
goes to tap on the little thingy we're
not in a movie
okay well you know you're in the game
maybe that's just what they want you to
think man
okay so this phone's a no-go
no one has signal is there anywhere else
in the camp that has a landline
well not a landline
what
the radio hut has some
old broadcast gear
where you do your announcements
where i curate my sweet summer jams yeah
and where i do the pa announcements it
has some old
equipment there i think we could
probably break something up and get a
message out
all right awesome let's go
let's head over there and see if we can
contact somebody put that back dylan
no we're keeping that [ __ ] crazy if
you think i'm going to go out there
without something to defend myself it's
more of a safety concern no we're
keeping this gun
we're keeping this gun
don't be a dick man i know how to use
this
okay uh
it's it's probably the this dude
probably the weather what weather ryan
what red
weather the bears
bear and why does everyone blame
everything on bears
so for the sake of argument what if that
bear
that uh cut our phone line and just cut
out all the power what if that bear is
waiting for us out in the hallway
fair point thank you
[Laughter]
we should probably tell caitlyn that
we're going to the radiohead we're
probably freaked
yeah okay yeah let's go
oh god
yeah we should probably leave that with
caitlyn
well maybe we should just leave her with
your gun
i'm a much better shot than you oh god
okay i might be an amazing shot there's
a lot of aggressiveness going on in here
i might be
just give her your gun
[Music]
uh all right
you're right
caitlyn would use uh the gun a lot still
have mine
director nice to meet him i might let
you hold it
don't write a check that your ass can't
cash what
my ass has got quite the bank account
come here
okay it's like can i have a gun please
yeah that's weather
oh thank you so much dylan you're so
generous and handsome yeah no problem
don't mention it
okay okay here we go
oh good to see you after we start the
new chapter you want to call it quits
for the night uh time again is it what
time is it
uh
yeah streaming for about two hours
strength
strength can be surprising
more power oh no one's on raw power
tapping into a previously unknown energy
i suppose
we did find a lot of terror cars
we did find a lot of tarot cards and
with one hand it gives and with the
other shout out to 108 with the the two
dollar super chat thanks brother great
show much respect i
it was it was a good show man it was a
good show i enjoyed it the magician
that's the one you found the incredible
the unbelievable the mystical
sensational
perceptive manipulation
the work of a magician now you see it no
you don't go
and you wouldn't want to miss it
as always there's more to see
and as always the choice is yours
would you like to see
more do we want to see more do we want
to go in here blind
let's see more because we haven't we see
more it just shows you like
superb okay okay
they're gonna let's choose one
i'll let you choose strength
magician
now though you see like someone's death
in the future
so it's goodbye again
i'll leave you with this i don't know
remember who your friends are
remember who's looking out for you babe
look at this cat's leg
you can't see the girl
see who goes first next time we jump on
it will be me with nick
well so emma's dead
nick is hurt he's not dead
i feel like
his bruises and stuff should be on this
picture
don't don't you get what i'm saying
though
um
abigail was bitten
so she's infected with whatever is out
there but there might be a cure so she
still has a chance to you got her killed
let's just be real here she's dead i'm
so sad
so
i don't know when we're gonna continue
this
um
dylan
if you're still in the chat how long do
you think we have left playing the game
i'm kind of curious because i kind of
want to go back
and try out other
things try other things
like other scenarios i feel like there
is a lot of decisions i just feel like
there's some decisions that don't feel
like their decisions like don't call out
but then when you don't call out he
still calls out i feel like that's a
little weird but yeah tell me how long
is left in this playthrough
interesting game though so far it's an
interesting game
and i i still think until dawn is better
but i haven't beat this yet so
until dawn is that the game that you
started
yeah until dawn i do think it's a better
game
but i finished until dawn i haven't
finished this game
[Music]
um
[Music]
about a bunch of people on the mountain
it's the same concept just different
story
oh yeah the about the they went to the
cabin yeah alone okay yeah all right so
um
i guess dylan's not in here any longer i
appreciate we're coming through we're
gonna end this little early this time